talk most of the time in this talk at a
different level at the talking about
species trees and Extinction and
speciation rates but I want to Circle
back to some of the issues that have
come up so far in this workshop and look
at population level inferences at the
end of this talk but for most of it I'm
going to be working at the species
level and the talk that I'm going to
give is comes out of a comparative
literature but kind of marries two
different sorts of comparative questions
we might want to ask when we're looking
at the tree of life the first type of
comparative
question looks at how does a trait
influence species and uh speciation and
Extinction rate and the classic way to
do this was by using sister species
analyses that compared groups that say
were herbivorous insects versus non
orborous insects and they would look in
the tree of life and say which is more
diverse which has more species and if
you repeated that sister CLA analysis
again and again and again you'd have
enough power to make inferences like
mitol did that her biver increases
diversification rates and there's a
whole series of of papers taking this
approach another type of comparative
analysis question though asks a
different type of question it takes a
look at the tree of life and says Where
have the transitions occurred and in
what direction do they tend to occur for
example you might ask with viery
mangroves are interesting because they
are vorous the seed grows in immediately
into the plant but also it's very salt
tolerant and so if we reconstruct the um
evolution of this trait has it evolved
multiple times or has it only evolved
once and is a shared characteristic of
that single evolutionary transition so
that's a single s another type of
question that you might ask about the
tree of
life but what if you are actually
interested in Evol in an evolving trait
that influences this the shape of the
tree that influences the speciation and
Extinction rate you can't actually
separate out ancestral Reconstruction
from effects on speciation and
Extinction rate because that same trait
is influencing the shape it's
influencing the philogyny or the graph
that we see thinking of philogyny as a
graph the shape of it depends on that
trait so one implication is that divers
if the trait influences the rate of
speciation and Extinction rate then
those rates the speciation and
Extinction rate leading to lineages That
You Don't See varies across this tree
Sister Clay analysis deal with that
variation by trying to ignore it largely
focusing in on those sister clades where
you see a difference between um with one
tra on one side and the other tra of the
other side of that node and ignoring the
rest of the tree um and losing some
power and doing so
one of the other issues if you do a
sister plate analysis and drop the rest
of the tree though is that of course you
can't tell it's a sign test so you can't
tell what makes a particular trait like
oriver and insx a more diverse clay
whether it's a higher speciation rate or
they're less prone to going extinct so
you lose that piece of information too
as well as losing power by just asking
which is more diverse than the
other
the other um problem that arises and I
think this is underappreciated is that
trait inference is misled if that trait
influences speciation and Extinction
rates and here's just a cartoon issue uh
example of that problem so that you can
see why it is a problem so let's let's
say that you know um from the rest of
the tree or from previous data that um
the purple and the green are equally
likely to go extinct
well then you might infer likelihood and
parsimony methods would both infer that
the ancestral State here is likely
purple there's just not that much time
separating those two but what if instead
I told you the rest of the tree or other
data says purple is a really Extinction
prone
state well then that'll shift the
likelihood that this ancestor was purple
towards green because it had to persist
long enough to lead to two descendant
lineages
so that makes it more likely that it was
actually in the non-extinction prone
state and transition twice to the
extinction prone state so there's an
example just as a thought um experiment
that you cannot infer ancestral States
if those States influence the shape of
the
tree so we've been using um developing
likelihood methods and by we I mean
primarily um Wayne Madison my colleague
at UBC and um my PhD student Rich Fitz
John so we've been developing likelihood
methods to infer parameters of Interest
along a
philogyny and you and what are these
parameters of Interest so I'm going to
walk us through the model um
construction before that so so a trade
here it could be one gene or many genes
responsible for it or you going to so a
trait can be anything it can be whether
you're sexual or asexual I'll give you
an example of that later it can be
whether or not you are in the tropics or
in the temperate zone so it could be a
geographic Association or could be an
amino acid presence or absent at the
site so trait is very broadly defined so
the model I'm going to take us through
is a multi-state branching process where
we're going to ask what can happen over
a period of time along a
tree so there's a whole bunch of
different processes that could happen
and we have parameters for each of it
the each of them the pop the lineage
could go extinct and that Extinction
rate mu can depend on the state of the
lineage AG there can be transitions from
one state to the other from State Z to
one so from sexual to asexual or vice
versa and there can also be speciation
events those are repres those are what
caus the nodes to appear in our tree or
the lineage can continue as is and these
are all forward time
rates so the goal is if we can come up
with a likelihood of seeing our data
seeing the philogyny as well as the tip
States
then we can estimate parameters like are
the extinction rates different for these
two traits or are they the same are the
speciation rates different or the
same so the question is how do we
develop that
likelihood until you go down the tree
you develop differential equations and
Tada but I I rather than doing the
standard thing of saying just take my
word at it I think it's actually quite
instructive to see how we derive these
likelihoods and so I'm going to turn
this off because it's no help and go to
the
board so I just want to give you a
flavor for how these calculations are
performed the basic um quantity that we
want to calculate is what I'm going to
call
D and D is the probability I'm going to
draw some you know this is the tree as
it exists above us and here we are at
some point in time
T and so there's a you know there's a
philogyny up here and there's trait
States up here and all of that is
considered the data and this is the
probability D and um is the probability
let's say that you're in state zero at
that point at time T in the past what is
the probability that everything that you
see from that point on will have
descended from this point so you'll
you'll see this philogyny as is you'll
see the traits among those extent
species as is and nothing else so what
you see is what you
get so what we have to do to derive a
dynamical equation for um this process
then is ask what would happen over a
small interval of time as we go P um
further back in time how would that
probability of seeing what we see
change so that's fairly straightforward
we're okay now we're back a little
little bit in time
can you see the red
okay and all we have to do is ask what
are all the possible things that could
have happened in that little bit of time
and how would they change the
probability well let's do the easy one
first it could have gone extinct in that
little interval of time but then you got
a problem because you can't explain the
data that you see so that will have be
associated with a probability of zero of
seeing the data that you see assuming
we're actually on a part of the tree
that's on the tree the other possibility
is that there could have been a
transition from state zero to one in
that small little period of time and
then we can still explain the data as
um um evolving the way it has evolved
but we would be explaining it from the
other state from the D1 State rather
than the d0o
state and then the last of the processes
that could happen that uh we're focusing
on is an is a speciation event
in this little period of
time now what I'm talking about is
moving down a lineage and there's
actually not a branch in that little
period of time that is we're on a on a
branch not at a node in this little time
interval but that doesn't mean that
there wasn't a speciation event there
there could have been but if that if
there was a speciation event there that
lineage would have had to have gone
extinct by the
present now that lineage might have even
Diversified further speciated more but
then all of the sub branches would have
had to go extinct so I'm just going to
introduce a new variable call that
e for the probability that um a lineage
a l so D is the probability of seeing
the
data that descends from a particular
point in time
T and E is the probability at a lineage
existing at time
T leaves no
descendants so if there was a speci and
event there that's fine but we would
have had to have the daughter lineage go
extinct but one one correction to this
we don't know whether that daughter
lineage is metaphorically on the right
or the left it's either one could have
gone extinct so there's two two ways for
that to happen so there's a two in front
of
there and those are all of the possible
events that can happen in the tree and
then of course you have the possibility
that nothing happens in that little
interval of
time and then you explain the data by D
didn't state zero
again what was
that two lambda0 Delta fine
but no no no no it's not the Lambda Zer
is the probability that n a speciation
ofit happens in this little interval of
time land 0 times um delta T it might be
easier to think about it as putting the
extinction rate the two in front of the
extinction rate because either sub bran
either resulting Branch can go
extinct all right so this is all fine
this is then you can shrink the time
interval turn it into a differential
equation and numerically solve this down
the tree of course I introduced another
variable along the way which means we
actually have to do the same thing for E
of zero but the method is now fairly
clear that in a particular lineage alive
at time T will go extinct and not leave
any descendants well it there's three
things that could happen along a little
time interval there could be an
Extinction event well that's great if
that happens then the probability that
the lineage goes extinct by the present
is now
one because it has just
happened or there could be a transition
to the other state but then we have the
same problem the lineage still has to go
extinct but it has to do so by the
present now in state
one and finally there can be a a
speciation rate in that little period of
time but now we've got two problems
we've got two lineages I have to go
extinct by the present assuming they're
independent that would then give us a
square of their Extinction
rates
yeah you're not oh thank you that's
right very good because you also have to
explain the branch that
survives
okay I think that's just double check
we're done those are the those are the
calculations needed to perform the this
descent down a tree to explain this data
that we see there's also a chance that
that nothing happens in the extinction
case
y z *
T and you also have tip states to
consider as well but those are fairly
trivial um starting conditions
for example the probability of seeing an
Extinction event at Time Zero given that
you that the lineage is there is zero
you can't there's no time for it to go
extinct similarly if I'm taking a look
at a particular Branch along this tree
and it's in state one then the
probability for that branch that I can
explain the data given that it was in
state zero is zero because it won't have
time to turn into State one and time and
that in no time but if I allow it to be
in state one then I can explain the
data and we'll come back to that in a
second so you go down the tree at nodes
you account for the speciation rate
itself happening in that little interval
of time and as I mentioned that's
proportional to
Landa um in the state that the system is
in and the little um interval of time
all right so I think that gets us back
back to the slides any questions
about roughly that method so we've got
differential now we've got four
differential equations if you've got a
trait that is binary trait in two states
zero and one and as we go down the tree
we're calculating this probability of
seeing what we see descended from that
point so once we're at the root of the
tree we sum over the root states to get
an overall likelihood of observing the D
um and having done that now that you
have a likelihood here's the chance of
seeing this train the chance of seeing
The Descendant taxa with their states we
can then do likelihood ratio tests or um
mcmc analyses to infer things about the
traits effects on speciation Extinction
so I'm going to Breeze
through the first part the next two
slides which um look at a simulation
test of the method so these are Sim
ulations forward in time of 500 taxs on
trees using specific effects on the
speci U specific parameters for all of
the speciation Extinction and transition
rates and these are this is actually a
summary of two sets of simulations
either where the speciation and
Extinction rates are the same sorry
speciation rates are the same for the
two traits so the trait has no effect
for these Hollow parameter estimates and
then in the second set of parameters one
of the speciation was double the other
set of parameters so those are the solid
points and the point of this set of
simulations was that the method does
fairly well on average of getting the
right parameter estimates out and can
distinguish cases where the speciation
rates are equal from cases where the
speciation rates are unequal so this was
just looking for whether there were
biases in the method that were
particularly strong now I should say
that speciation is typically better
estimated than transition rates and
Extinction rates across this tree
there's so the red point is an average
over all of the inferences and it's
still accurate but you can see a lot
more noise especially with the
extinction rate estimate so there's no
there is signal there it's just less
signal and at an intuitive level the P
Tre mainly provides us with an estimate
of how fast it's growing the growth rate
and the growth rate is called the net
diversification rate or the speciation
minus the extinction rate so most of the
tree provides us information about that
how fast it's
diversifying most of the signal about
the extinction rate is coming from the
tips and whether or not you see more
tips in the tree than you'd expect based
on how the whole group has Diversified
and you'd expect a Tippy tree if this um
those character States lead to a very
high Extinction rate because those new
baby species that have just Arisen
haven't had time to go extinct yet and
sha NE labeled this the pole of the
presence in his lineage over time plots
where you'd see the signal of Extinction
is mainly coming from recent tips of the
tree and the question and what this
method is using to infer a difference in
extinction rate is whether or not that
pull of the present depends on the
character State that's at an intuitive
level so I'm not telling it that that's
what it should
use can I answer question I hope it's
just about the simulations themselves
but sometimes you didn't get a tree yes
this is conditional Sean following sha
n's um assumption we condition on there
being two branches in your
tree now you could say You must have you
would never do a f a comparative
analysis on a tree with two spe species
so that conditioning it on a much more
sophisticated will only bother doing
this analysis with X number of taxa and
this amount of variation in the taxa is
something that should be thought about
well I was just wondering about if we
can imagine if we want to think Beyond
to the world of viation analysis we only
get reported certain
trees Y is that where you headed
probably I'm going to I'm going to head
there in a little way and and and check
I suspect there's more hidden bugaboos
than what I'm going to talk about but
I'm going to talk about one of
them um and that's going to come up
really soon so this method is great in
that it allows you to dis to disentangle
speciation and Extinction remember the
sister CL analysis does not allow you to
distinguish the two so this is the first
method that will give you estimates for
speciation rates and their differences
and Extinction rates and their
differences and you can run it in R blah
blah blah but here here's the first
Bugaboo that re requires so far it
requires full philogenetic information
that's an impossibility most trees you
don't have you don't have a full tree of
a particular group you have a subsample
tree so that's that's the Bugaboo that I
want to talk about next so this method
would basically be unusable if we
required that because remember I said I
did we did simulations with 500 taxa
there's not a huge amount of signal in
philogenetic trees if you want estimates
of speciation and Extinction R you have
to have big trees but you don't need
complete
trees um and and and I'm going to show
you just briefly the two methods that
we've used for incomplete trees the
first method is actually a fairly simple
one if the species on your tree is a
random sample of
species nobody ever samples randomly but
if they did then that's actually easy to
incorporate because it's really like
there's an extra sampling step on top of
the present and so all we have to do is
account for the fact that not only did
that species have to survive to the
present in that state but we also had to
sample it so it just changes the
starting conditions on this method and
you can do that in a fairly
sophisticated way you don't have to
assume that they're the same sampling
processes for sexuals and asexuals you
can have those be different rates and
you can also fine-tune it if you know
I've well sampled in this clave and
poorly sampled in those this clave then
you can give them different sampling
properties the other method that you can
that we've used which is a more
complicated one is let's say sometimes
people will say I've got this one
species that's representing my genus so
this is my genus and I've got one
species on my tree and here's another
genus and I've got one species on my
tree so the philogyny is kind of samp
over dispersed in its sampling with one
member representing a clay and so the
philogyny um I'm saying there's
unresolved information you know the rest
of the genus you're assuming the rest of
the genus Falls in this part of the tree
but you don't know how it's resolved so
for that sort of data if that's a data
set you have then you can use forward
time multi type branching models to say
what's the probability of going from one
lineage to seeing all all of this
diversity that you see at the present in
that clay it's limited numerically to
you really can't go above clayes of size
200 otherwise it goes crazy but that at
least allows you to use all of your
information you may know for example
that there
are 50 asexual species and two the other
way 50 sexual species and two asexual
species in this CLA and you can use that
information by asking what's the chance
of going from one to 52 species two of
which have the right State okay so the
the next question is well when you when
you don't have all the information how
much do you lose do we really need
fairly complete trees before we have a
good power to estimate processes across
the
philogynes and this was this was one of
those moments looking in these graphs I
was like wow that's great news
so what what have I got here let's focus
on this side this is um 500 species
trees 250 species trees symmetric that's
not very meaningful that means that the
speciation rates were actually the same
asymmetric means that there was a
difference in the speciation rate but
the x- axis is what's really interesting
so well let's start with the y- axis
this is the confidence interval for a
particular um difference in the
diversification rate so on this left
hand side there's no difference in
diversification rate and the width of
this bar tells us how confident we are
in our inference across the
simulation and this is where we've
dropped this x-axis say how many of
those 500 species do we drop from our
analysis before running the inference
and then this is where it's quite
interesting we actually don't lose much
confidence until we're down to almost 50
species and the reason for that I think
is that by and large there so much
ticity in any one realization of the
tree of life and that's already
accounted for in this likelihood process
that you don't actually need you need
kind of just a skeleton representation
of that tree to get most of the data out
now I should say that those confidence
intervals widen faster for extinction
rates which is again consistent with a
view that Extinction is largely coming
information is largely coming from the
tips of the Tree of Life the other thing
I want to point out is there's two sets
of lines here this is a confidence
interval for that method where the
missing taxs that we knew where they
were and we use that terminal clay
method and put them in the right spots
in the tree and that remains more
powerful for
longer the sampling method where we say
we don't know where those missing tacks
are but they come from somewhere in the
tree is a little less powerful but I
think the bottom line message is quite
interesting you don't need the full tree
to get inferences out on speciation and
Extinction but this depends
to oh I'm yes
I'm and yeah so you only have a few
samples get long branches then
you then you lose your
information that's right and so this you
know so we
can we can see a little bit like that
here by just comparing these two grass
this only has 250 species and so we lose
that information faster because we end
up with those long terminal branches
sooner than um we do down here when we
have quite a squishy 500 species TRS but
now the other point that you raise is
whenever you do a simulation study of a
particular method it depends on what
parameters you've happened to choose so
we're going to ignore that and go on but
no that's a really good question one of
the things that we don't know is how
much we can break the assumptions of the
method and still get decent inferences
out I'll talk about that a little bit at
the end too so the other the what we
we've done recently is look at other
types of traits so you can look at
quantitative traits for example body
size or sexual dimorphism and now now
what you're inferring is not these
discrete probabilities of um seeing The
Descendant taxa in a particular state
but now you have a
function of of um any particular body
size for example and the speciation rate
and the extinction rates are also
functions non- negative functions for
example you might be interested in
having in seeing whether the speciation
rate increases with body size that might
be your the question that you're
interested in and you may be testing
that against a null hypothesis where the
speciation rate does not depend on body
size the other the other questions that
you may want to look at are okay you
started by looking at whether or not the
um organism was asexual or sexual for
example but what what if you also know
that perenniality or some other trait is
correlated with that first trait and you
want to know well which is it that's the
um better predictor or better is better
associated with speciation and
Extinction rate differences and to be
able to answer that question you have to
be able to fit these trees to more than
one character so that's one of the
things we've done or to multiple states
of a single character the other thing
that is a fairly easy extension to do is
here when I did the speciation rate I
assume that the daughter was also in the
same state zero but could be that the
trait that you're interested in is
actually the driver of the speciation
event that is the character change U the
character changed because the speciation
event happened polyploidization for
example could drive speciation or if you
have a niche uh um Evolution into a new
Niche it could be that character
transition allowed the speciation event
but that's fairly easy to incorporate
because you then kind of unpack this
event and say well yes but at that
speciation event there's a probability
of changing states as well and then you
follow the same equations but allowing
for that possibility so it allows you to
get at how much of the change do we see
across the tree is happening at the
nodes of the tree and how much is
happening along the branches and
importantly when I say nodes of the tree
this doesn't just mean the nodes that we
see it means the speciation events also
that happen along Ong the branches that
we don't see because some of their
daughters went
extinct so this for example if all of
those um species went extinct we also
want to be able to say oh yeah that
event actually was Associated that
speciation event was actually associated
with a transition between zero and one
even if we don't see that node
today okay so that's another um
extension and I'm I'm just going to do a
quick run through an empirical example
and then talk about related issues um
within a
population so this is a project that it
we did with Mark Johnson of University
of Toronto Miss Saga and he had
developed this philogyny of a group of
evening primroses known as
inthera en was a classic flower studied
by De because of this incredible ring
chromosome structure due to a series of
translocations between their chromosomes
their whole genome of some of these
xenoa are tied up in a ring so every
single chromosome is kind of pairing up
with the ends of another chromosome all
the way through their entire genome
these ring structures then during
meiosis rather than segregating each
chromosome independently the ring gets
pulled apart with one the maternal ring
being separated from the paternal ring
and crazily enough in these Zena Thea
that are effectively asexual itself puts
together that maternal and paternal
genome and recreates the parental
genome crazy system so it breaks apart
its genome and puts it back together
every generation and that system of it's
called permanent translocation
heterozygosity because um you never see
mother mother genomes coming together e
and it why depends on the species in
some species you only get the matal
going into the pollen and the maternal
going into the Alves in other species
you can get the other type of seeds
produced but the maternal maternal
genomes carry um lethal homo or lethal
because of the homozygosity throughout
the genome anyway take a look at this
tree so this is the distribution of this
asexual like State called pth across the
tree of life so red is asexual blue is
sexual and um this tree tree Marx tree
had 113 of the 260 known pth taxa in the
clay all right
so oh and I should say also this is a
sample of the trees there's a lot of
philogenetic uncertainty and the graphs
I'm about to show are mcmc graphs over
that pH that a set of philogynes as
opposed to assuming one particular phogy
all right so this is what that data what
the inference is from the method what
the truth is we don't
know so the pink is the asexual type the
pth type and the method infers that the
pth type actually species the asexual
type species at a higher significantly
higher rate than the sexual
types we actually had a reviewer say
that's not theoretically
possible but it's it's actually what I
would say is the null prediction in that
asexual ual types don't have to worry
about or they don't have gene flow
perturbing the buildup of locally
adapted Gene complexes throughout the
gene so it's much easier for an asexual
type to become locally adapted and
potentially to um
speciate the other thing that was a
surprise was I was expecting okay maybe
they speciate more often but they might
also go extinct more often the asexual
and the needes we didn't actually see
that the extinction rates um were
overlapping you can see the prior in
this little dash line in there and um
this Extinction rate differences
whatever they were were not big enough
to um affect the difference in
speciation rate so that the net
diversification rate was still higher
for the pth lineage than the um sexual
lineages what's interesting though is
this last graph which says that okay
they didn't go extinct but they went
back to sex quite
often so the in inference there thanks
is that rather than seeing this asexual
State as a as a dead end that is
extinction prone these lineages may be
trying it out trying out asexuality and
then coming back to sex and that's also
consistent with theories about what a
what the problems of asexuality are for
example Muller's ratchet or the
inability to adapt due to Hill Robertson
effects or what have you may lead
eventually to a ual an asexual
population that is quite prone to being
invaded by a sexual
reverent that a sexual sublineage if it
arises within this population
introducing more genetic variation can
spread and you can kind of see hints in
the tree of where that signal is coming
from it's coming from these first of all
you can see that the often times the red
the pth is associated with a small the
the um rapid
um speciation branches parts of the sub
tree consistent with a view that it's
promoting speciation but you also see
these blue lineages embedded within the
otherwise asexual clayes and those are
the ones that Mark is looking into to
seeing if there is evidence in these
clades that they may have reverted back
that they have asexual ancestors that
went back to sex so stay tuned um and
and that's a good example of where I
don't know that this is the truth I
suspect it's unlikely to be the truth
but it provides an alternative
hypothesis most people working in this
group had not consider the possibility
that there could be reversions and the
reversions are not that um hard to
imagine these plants still produce um
pollen they still produce flowers and
mating between Rel related species could
put back together maternal maternal
genomes or you could get a series of
translocations that undo enough of that
ring structure to allow recom mination
to um re arise
again one other um example and then I
want to turn to my last point this other
example um is by it my former postto
meos and others and here we were looking
at a trait which is poly and we were
asking does polyploidy lead is it an
evolutionary dead end or does it lead to
diversification and for those of you who
have been reading the literature on the
um two rounds of polyploidization and
the lineages leading up to vertebrates
to us and other vertebrates there's a
lot of contention there some people say
it's because of those polyploidization
events that um we as successful or as
diverse a group as we
are but others including steans who
first wrote about polypoid he said
polyploids have a problem and that every
single um the new mutations when they
arise they're very very well masked by
the large number of Gene copies at that
at each gene so polyploids in terms of
rates of adaptation should be quite
sluggish and in that sense they may be
more prone to
Extinction we looked at this so the
previous analysis was on one clay we
looked at this at 63 different clayes of
plants asking was there a consistent
signal on the effect of Floy on
diversification rates and here is a
histogram of those 63 different analyses
asking what's the probability across
your mcmc runs that the diploid was the
one that was more diverse and you can
see it's very right skewed the diploid
was more often diverse and the polyploid
less
diverse and we see that's driven by two
things there's a diploids tend to
speciate more and they tend to go
extinct at a slightly lower rate now
remember this is at the genus level and
so at the genus level this implies that
polyploids may arise a lot but they're
not persisting for very long and so by
and large the likely fate of a polyploid
lineage that first arises is to go
extinct more likely than if it hadn't
ization leaning to us made much of a
difference because that's really asking
about much deeper events and whether or
not those much deeper events had an the
ones that do survive the polyploids that
do
survive um allow the subsequent lineages
to diversify because of that extra um
gen um genetic degrees of freedom
provided by poly poiz so open question
about deeper Parts in the
tree so the the last um um part that I
wanted to talk about in the context of
this conference was what does so these
are birth death
models and I've been talking about them
as if you as if your data is about
species but what if you have data from
within a species and you have a
philogyny from within a species can you
use these
methods um and St and and the advantage
of doing this is that you can kind of
avoid the ancestral selection graph
because the birth death model assumes
independence of your different lineages
and just asks whether a particular trait
increases the branchiness bushiness of
the tree that you
see um as a proof of principles staer
and boner applied a um this method they
um had to modify it a little bit because
they were using it with HIV data and HIV
data not all of the sequences were
sampled at the same time but they had
data sets where they was sampling at
different points in time and they had to
account for that sampling process as
well but they were able to um detect
differences now speciation wasn't
speciation that it was transmission to a
different individual where it was in one
individual before the branching that
they're interested in is that one
lineage and one individual became
lineages and two individuals and they
were able to detect a difference in the
diversification rate with um a higher
transmiss ability from through
intervenience Doug user hosts then
heterosexual host with their HIV 1
philogyny and the last graph that I'll
show you ask the following question
getting back to Richard's question about
how much can we break the tree and still
have it work one of the breaks that I'm
interested in is what if it's wrong that
it's a birth death model What If instead
it's actually a fixed population size
model like a coalescent type model and
here we've done Sim ulations using a
Moran model and that's got a fixed
population size and every time you
sample one species or one type to give
birth you randomly sample another type
to go extinct or to
die and so we that's that's the opposite
type this has strong density dependence
you always have n individuals in your
sample and you simulate it but you ask
if there's a difference between your
types in their Fitness in their birth
rates or in their speciation rates then
what will this method infer
about those differences in birth rates
and so here's a set of simulations we're
just starting this and this is with Carl
Roth BS at EBC we're just starting this
but in this set of simulations there was
no difference in the birth rate and the
inferred difference in speciation rate
or birth rate using the birth death
model that I've been telling you about
is centered on zero with a very small
um false um positive rate of 3
.4% and over here we have there actually
was a difference in Fitness and one type
was more fit than the other type and
there with this tree we were able to
detect a difference in the birth rates
of um so the true difference was um 10%
or 0.1 sorry and it was well centered
and we have a decent power with these
trees of inferring the higher Fitness of
the one type over the other type
so I think this is suggestive as another
way so what does this need you need a
philogyny of a particular region you
need to be able to say I'm interested in
say an amino acid difference and I want
to infer what the effects of that amino
acid are on the tra the shape of the
tree you also need to be able to say
something about how you sampled your
sequences because this method is really
critically dependent on properly
describing your sampling design it has
to go into your likelihood analysis
otherwise something that you don't
sample will be thought will be will
mimic an Extinction event so you have to
be very clear about your um sampling
design but any rate it I think it's
interesting because it suggests another
way we might be able to detect selection
if we can get such um
philogynes within species and I think
going back to the last talk of course
you also have to account for
recombination but you could imagine
applying these methods
across your different inferred blocks
with their different philogynes within a
within a group all right thank
you
questions so what would happen if you
started thinking about the range the
geographic range of species so one
extreme will be to say there's a very
broad range and then it's split up to M
and then there's clearly nonindependence
on the other hand you can imagine
sympatric speciation where you have more
species sa how do you do with that no
that's a that's a messy messy trait of
like do you want to take the midpoint
range or do you want to take the upper
and lower limits of your trait um yeah
and then I think it depends exactly on
what your model of speciation rate is so
for the clay Genet let's say that you
believe that new species are formed at
the edge of a um range and that they bud
so then that's say that's a clay to
Genesis model where your trait is small
for one daughter species and larger for
the other daughter species and you could
do that in a quantitive framework but
it's assumption there's a lot of
assumptions I think when you deal with
range because you could you could
imagine a different way that there's
there's um some Patric speciation across
the full range and the daughter species
has the same range size as the parent so
there's I think there's some traits that
for which they're too messy we don't
know enough about their process of
evolution I think to use them I was
wondering if we can deal with some Gin
flow between species and and the fact
that maybe might occur more often in
this shallow part of the tree that's a
really good question and I think an open
one with respect to how it influences
these so that's another way we can break
the model for the plant data we tended
to use chloroplast data for the trees to
avoid the very sticky issue when you're
dealing with popoids often which form
through
hybridization um but no I very good
question is it sensitive to a really low
rate
of migration events oration events don't
know don't know at
all
Andy the the example isn't there a big
difference in the definition of
speciation and the sexuals and asexuals
I lovea it's such a great example it's
it's one of the best to have done this
sort of analysis because they still
produce pollen and how they assess the
species concept is even for the asexuals
they use the biological species concept
they take pollen from one plant and
cross it to the ovules of another plant
and actually see if it produces viable
seed that's fine but still in terms of
the actual process of splitting it's
like there just separate clonal lineages
are now called species asexuals no
that's right in the asexuals they're
defined by the biological species
concept whereas if you were working
because they do the crossability study
but if you were looking at rotifers or
something else where there's no there's
no biological species concept that you
can use for the asexual because you
can't cross them then you'd be really
stuck you you'd have to use you have to
use the same species metric across your
tree otherwise you're
confounding um your are our human
definition of species with the
speciation rate
differences but with en Thea that's an
unusual one where you can still use the
biological species
concept it sounds like you're puzzled
over that it just seems like the the the
number of genetic events required to
establish this incompatibility for an
asexual lineage it could just be one Le
one last transation always as
Aon to speciate yeah which is why I
think we that allow that is consistent
with the inference of a higher
speciation rate for the um asexuals
putting it another way the asexuals were
faster at developing um
biological um reproductive
isolation than they sexual plates proba
possibly because they're not mixing up
those genes so with respect of Andy's
question or this issue and going back to
your poly PL it seems to me like an
interesting observation which I think
exists for the polyps at least is that
some polyploids as you you know better
than I arise as a single maybe
individual yeah and other ones arise as
some kind of hybrid swarm where there's
quite a bit of genetic diversity y the
same thing I I'm embarrassed to say I
don't know the situation in N about
whether there's any indication of these
asexuals arise through some kind of
population phenomena as opposed to
individual that seems to me like it's
very relevant to Extinction absolutely
um I can tell you that one thing we're
trying to investigate is polypoid are
typically classified into two main
classes autopolyploids and alop
polyploids and the data that we had
could not distinguish them but we're
trying to build up a data set where we
can say does it matter are alop
polyploids much more likely to persist
than autop
polyploids do we know about or these
things ever
AR
where's Mark I don't know I I don't know
that multiple origin I know multiple
Origins is known to to be fairly common
in polypoid Plants I don't know about
any there was a question there any more
questions Moran models yeah um what
other parameters did you have in there
besides the population besid the Nal 150
right so um so the main parameters of
the model were the um birth rate in
state zero and the birth rate in state
one and then the way we simulated it so
those could be different but then when
one thing went was born another type
went extinct at random and you can flip
it around and do the mor model the other
way so I think those are the only
two yeah they were the the birth rates
were the same and on the one on the left
the birth rate was higher for one Ty so
that's
don't um so those simulations were we
did the simulation did a tree applied
bsy the method for inference and said
Can busy which does not assume a Moran
model but assumes a birth death model
can it infer a difference in the the in
the birth rates so that's what those
simulations were reporting and and I
think that that's an example where the
method um is not that sensitive to to
simulating your phogy um assuming a
constant n versus assuming a birth death
model that doesn't have a constant n but
for other way other breaks to the
Assumption we still don't have a really
good sense of what you can break and
what you can't
break other
questions no let's thank the speakers
again